nous ne menaçons personne, nous sommes venus ou quelque chose
jusqu'aux frontières des États-Unis ou aux frontières
la grande-bretagne se réjouit est venue à nous et
maintenant ils disent toujours non maintenant l'ukraine
sera à l'OTAN, et il y aura des systèmes
ou ne pourrait-il pas être nécessaire avec lui sur un aller-retour
la base sera la base et le système de choc
des armes, mais c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
vous exigez une sorte de garantie de ma part
vous devez nous donner des garanties et immédiatement
à présent
ils en parlent depuis des décennies et moins
une si douce conversation sur le besoin
assurer la sécurité pour tout le monde
ce qui est prévu mais c'est de cela qu'il s'agit mais
menaçons-nous quelqu'un